I think I was always informally thinking
about choice from when I was a very
young child because I was born to seek
immigrant parents so is constantly going
back and forth between a Sikh household
and an American outside world so it's
going back and forth between very
traditional Sikh home in which you had
to follow the five K's you know never
cut your hair always carry around a comb
never take off your underwear other than
I mean never take off your gonna wear it
even if it was in the shower dressed
very conservatively and so I was living
growing up in a very traditional
household and yet at the same time I was
going to school in the United States
where I was taught the importance of
personal preference so at home it was
all about learning your duties and
responsibilities whereas in the school
it was all about well you get to decide
what you want to eat you get to decide
how you're gonna lock and what you're
gonna be when you grow up and when
people learn that my parents actually
had an arranged marriage people thought
that was the most horrific thing on
earth I mean how could anybody allow
their their marriage of all things to be
prescribed by somebody else and you know
I went home and they seemed my parent
seemed normal it didn't seem to feel
like somehow they had been victims of
some Nazi camp or something so it was
constantly going back and forth between
these two cultures that kept raising the
question well how important is personal
freedom and I think that has always been
of interest to me then the other thing
that affected my interest in choice I
was growing up was the fact that I was I
was going blind and that meant that
there were lots of questions that
constantly kept arising about how much
choices I actually could have so on the
one hand in school your teachers are
constantly telling you that you can be
whatever it is you want to be as long as
you put your mind and heart to it and
yet at the same time I was also getting
the clear message of well what can you
do really I mean can you walk to school
on your own can you study science can
you study math can you go to a normal
school do you need to go to a special
school what's gonna become of you when
you grow up are you gonna have to live
on Social Security and SSI you're gonna
be able to shave your legs you're gonna
be able to get married
so it was constantly thinking about both
both choice in terms of possibilities I
mean because choice is the thing that's
supposed to I'll enable you to be
whatever it is you want to be and yet at
the same time you have to think about
choice in terms of its limitations and I
think that too ended up affecting a lot
of the different research questions that
I later asked was really was about well
to what extent how do we balance choice
as possibility and choice as limitations
I don't know if I approached choice any
differently than the sighted people do
but I what I am very cognizant of is
that choice does have limits and because
of that I really try to take advantage
of the domains in which I do have choice
and when I do have choice I try to be
very picky about or shall I say choosy
about when I choose I don't
automatically decide that I must be the
one to choose or that it's important for
me to make every choice in my life I
pick what are my priorities and I limit
those priorities to less than five in my
life and really in those particular
areas put in the energy to try to make
good choices so I think of choosing is a
both a fun and an effortful activity and
I think of choice is something that in
order for you to really get what you
want out of it you have to put a lot
into it and so I'm only willing to do
that for a few different things and for
the rest I really just try to either
satisfice come up with a very simple
rule or let somebody else make the
choice
so when I was a PhD student at Stanford
University I used to frequent this
grocery store called draeger is it you
know it was it's always a thrilling
experience to go into a place that
offers you a lot of choice you know it's
like it reminds you when you're a kid
and you go to the amusement park and
whether it be Disney we're all there are
Six Flags
you know you that moment that thrilling
moment when you first enter and you know
you've got all these possibilities for
the day and its really a it's a
wonderful feeling so it was to go to
this store called draggers and you have
a little bit of that same feeling
because this was a story that offered
you so many so many varieties things you
never contemplated before you know like
two hundred and fifty mustards and
vinegars and over 500 different kinds of
fruits and vegetables or over two days
and different types of watering and this
is at a time when you know most of us
trying tap water so I guess you go to
the store and examine all the varieties
and we just marvel at all the choices
out there but I found that I rarely
bought anything and I and I kind of
thought that was kind of curious I mean
they had things that the other grocery
stores didn't have and and yet I never
bought anything and so one day I went to
the manager and I asked him whether his
model was working and he said well
haven't you seen how many customers we
have in this store and yes indeed I had
I mean it was definitely attracting a
lot of customers even attracting
tourists buses that would land up at
this store and people go through the
store and marvel at all the options even
sometimes take photographs of the
various aisles so the manager agreed to
let me do a little experiment where we
put out a little tasting booth next to
the entry we either put out six
different flavors of jam or 24 different
flavors of jam and we looked at two
things first
in what case were people more likely to
be attracted to the jar of jam so in
which case are people more likely to
stop when they saw the display of jams
and what we felt was that more people
stopped when there were 24 jams about
60% of the people stopped when we had 24
jams on display and then at the times
when we had six different flavors of jam
out on display only 40 percent of the
people
I stopped so more people were clearly
attracted to the larger varieties of
options but then when it came down to
buying so the second thing we looked at
is in what case were people more likely
to buy a jar of jam what we found was
that of the people who stopped when
there were 24 different flavors of jam
out on display only 3 percent of them
actually bought a jar of jam
whereas over the people who stopped when
there were six different flavors of jam
30 percent of them actually bought a jar
of jam so if you do the math people were
actually 6 times more likely to buy a
jar of jam if they had encountered 6
then if they encountered 24 so what we
learned from this study was that well
people were more attracted to having
more options that's what sort of got
them in the door or got them to think
about jam when it came to choosing time
they were actually less likely to make a
choice if they had more to choose from
than if they had a fewer to choose from
and that really ended up starting an
entire area of research where we began
to look at well why is that and a large
part of that has to do with the fact
that when people have a lot of options
to choose from they don't know how to
tell them apart they don't know how to
keep track of them then they start
asking them so as well which one's the
best which one would be good for me and
that all those questions are much easier
to ask if you're choosing from sex and
when you're choosing from 24 and if you
look at the marketplace today most often
we have a lot more than 24 of things to
choose from in fact even in that store
draggers they had three hundred and
forty eight different kinds of jam
actually in the jam aisle and what we
found over about say 10 years of
research is that as the number of
choices actually increase people are
less likely to make a choice and
sometimes they do this even when it's
really bad for them like people are less
likely to invest in their retirement
when they have more options in their
401k plans than when they have fewer
people are even when they do make a
choice they're more likely to choose
things that are not as good for them you
know like they'll make worse financial
decisions for them if they're choosing
from a lot of options than
they're choosing from a few options if
they have more options they're more
likely to avoid stocks and put all their
money in money market accounts which
doesn't even grow at the rate of
inflation also if they choose for more
options than fewer options they're less
satisfied with what they choose and
that's true whether they're choosing
chocolates or which job offer to accept